YouTube has been caught despite all of its
claims that it's cleaning up its algorithm
actively promoting videos containing completely
anti scientific climate change denial.
This is based on a new report from Avaaz,
which I'm going to tell you about in a second.
Many of you know that over the last 18 months,
our YouTube channel has been absolutely crushed
by YouTube recommended video algorithm and
its monetization algorithm.
I'll have updated numbers for you from 2020
2019 in total later this week or early next
week.
I'm not going to retell the full details of
the story right now, but the gist of it is
that in late 2018 YouTube started promoting
so-called authoritative content over fringe
content and we were wrapped up in that.
What they've they've done effectively is recommend
corporate legacy YouTube channels like CNN,
MSNBC, and Fox news uses YouTube channels
over independent channels like ours, and it
has hurt us hugely.
I told you a couple of months ago that I believed
we were losing about two to 3 million views
per month since early 2019 but it turns out
that it's actually even worse than that.
If you go back to February of 2017 we got
more than 6 million views just from YouTube
recommendations.
That's not our whole channel.
That's just from the recommendations.
In December of 2019 it was 600,000 that is
a literal decimation of our recommended views.
The shortfall is as much as five and a half
million views in a month.
This is destroying the channel.
I truly, when I see those numbers, it's so
disheartening and crushing to see it.
Given what we have done over the last several
years to be a bigger and bigger part of the
discussion on YouTube and to see our recommendations
shrink to barely 10% of what they once were.
And then we find out because of this report
that Avaaz puts out, they look up 5,000 videos
which come up when you search terms, climate
change, global warming and related terms,
and then they look at 5,000 videos and then
they checked which videos is YouTube recommending
when you are watching those videos, right?
If you search for climate change and watch
a video, what does YouTube then suggest that
you watch in the up next bar of videos that
shows up next to or below the video you're
watching, depending on whether you're on mobile
or on a computer, depending on which search
term you used, anywhere from eight to 21%
of the videos that YouTube recommended you
watch.
Next included climate science denial of different
kinds.
21% is more than one out of five.
Now if YouTube said, we're not taking any
position on promoting authoritative content
over fringe, reliable content over conspiracies,
I'd say fine, they're not taking a position.
Their algorithm is not trying to promote authoritative
over fringe content and there's some climate
signs, denial stuff that has shown up, but
YouTube says we are going to promote authoritative
stuff over fringe content and conspiracy content
and it costs our channel two, three, five
and a half million views per month.
But supposedly it's worth it, right?
Because they're not promoting BS conspiracies
and fringe content.
And yet in some cases, one out of five climate
change recommendations are for climate science
denial conspiracy videos.
Now you might wonder why is the recommendation
algorithm so important?
There are so many ways people find videos,
things shared on social media, their subscriptions
feed, direct searches.
The up next feature, meaning this recommendations
algorithm dictates 70% of what people are
watching on YouTube and it is costing us anywhere
from two to three up to five and a half million
views per month.
And meanwhile, anti-science climate denial
nonsense is still being suggested by YouTube.
We have to fight this and unfortunately we
probably can't get YouTube to change its algorithm.
I am sending all of this data to my YouTube
rep seeing what they can do.
What we can do is directly support channels.
We value to ensure that they're not tied to
YouTube ad revenue.
I know I've said it before, that's that's
what we have to do.
For us, it's really easy.
Membership and patriotic.
Grab a membership on our website.
We've got a discount code that is 66% off.
That code is 2020 now.
Okay.
I don't care at what financial level you're
involved.
Even if it's two bucks a month using the code
2020 now do it.
You can also just throw a dollar or two hour
way on Patrion at patrion.com/david Pakman
show.
These are small amounts of money.
In some cases, if you're doing a dollar a
month, it's almost like a micropayment, but
it adds up when thousands of you do it, so
please consider it.
The situation is dire.
We are rapidly heading into an incredibly
important election with the YouTube recommendations
algorithm not recommending independent channels
like ours.
I'll have a full report
about
the data, uh, later this
week or early next.